Hello, and welcome to our new series—Crash
Course: History of Science.
My name is Hank Green, and I’ve wanted to
produce this course for years.
I’m obsessed with how people throughout
the ages have uncovered truths about the universe
and converted these into a wealth of technological
wonders.
This process has decreased the suffering of
millions of humans—even as it’s sparked
entirely new problems.
Regardless of the outcomes of scientific inquiry,
the process itself is fascinating.
The world you inhabit today is full of gadgets
that once belonged to science fiction.
We can model what the earth looked like millions
of years ago, or zoom in and observe the atoms
that make up our own bodies.
We are going to tell that inspiring story:
we’ll be thinking about thinking with Aristotle,
digging canals in Song Dynasty China,
listening to robot musicians in medieval Turkey,
fighting an electrical war in New York City,
and discovering the shape of DNA in Cold War
England.
But the history of science is not only a story
of humanity’s collective movement from ignorance
to knowledge, for two different reasons.
First, as much as scientists today may not
like to admit it, we are still pretty ignorant…
And we don’t agree on what it would mean
to reach the ultimate Truth, capital T.
Take a big question that we've been asking for a long time like “what is stuff”:
While modern physicists will tell you that
stuff is made of atoms, and atoms are made
of quarks and leptons, we still don’t know
why quarks exist.
Or why there appears to be far more matter
in the universe than we can account for.
Even something as basic as “stuff” needs
a lot more sciencing!
Second, and more importantly for historians,
“science” isn’t a stable or single idea.
That’s why, in this episode, we’re going
to be thinking about some ways to answer a deceptively
simple question:
what is the history of science the history
of?
[intro music plays]
Today, “science” can mean both our body
of knowledge about the world as well as the
methods we use to create that knowledge, or
how we know the stuff that we know.
Within that “how,” there are two main
practices—things that we do—that systematically
generate knowledge:
One: observe some specific aspect of the world.
For example, Darwin spent decades obsessively
observing the subtle variations in different
kinds of barnacles, orchids, turtles, birds,
and other living things.
This led him to theorize how they had changed
over time.
My dude loved barnacles!
Two: conduct an experiment to answer some
question about the world.
Did Galileo drop two metal balls of different
masses from the Leaning Tower of Pisa, to
show that they fall at the same rate and disprove
Aristotle’s theory of gravity?
Probably not.
But Dutch thinkers Simon Stevin and Jan Cornets
de Groot did conduct that experiment soon after.
Today, we have much bigger “towers” for
testing theories in physics: the Large Hadron
Collider is seventeen miles long!
Finally, when I said systematically, I meant
that there are rules about observing or experimenting—rules
that anyone can follow.
That notion of anyone being able to be a scientist
is super important.
In fact, a lot of contemporary scientists
have three Latin words tattooed on their arms:
“NULLIUS IN VERBA”—“on no one’s
word…”
Let’s explore this phrase because it's important.
In this series, The Thoughtbubble is going
to bring to life different wonders from the
history of science.
Today, our wonder is pretty abstract: the
wonder of the reproducible experiment.
“NULLIUS IN VERBA” is the motto of the
Royal Society.
This group of knowledge-makers was founded
in 1660 as a “College for the Promoting
of Physico-Mathematical Experimental Learning”
and re-founded in 1663 as “the Royal Society
of London for the Improvement of Natural Knowledge.”
And it’s still around today!
The Society was started as a place to debate
new ideas about nature.
Its members demonstrated experiments in front
of each other—“witnessing” the proofs
behind their theories.
They wrote up these theories in the Society’s
Philosophical Transactions, one of the world’s
oldest peer-reviewed scientific journals.
Influenced by Francis Bacon’s ideas, which
would eventually become associated with the
“scientific method,” the founding members
of the Royal Society chose a motto with an
unambiguous meaning:
don’t believe something just because someone
tells you it’s true.
Test out each new hypothesis, or educated
guess, yourself.
In other words: your individual proof of how
some natural phenomenon works should be something
that anyone can reproduce.
This idea had an enormous impact on the history
of science.
Later members of the Royal Society included
stars such as Ike Newton, Ben Franklin, Mike
Faraday, Chuck Darwin, and even Big Al Einstein,
who was about as British as sauerkraut.
In fact—plot twist!—the early scientists
who adopted the creed “NULLIUS IN VERBA”
were not actually “scientists.”
They were well-off alchemists and medical doctors,
and they called themselves Natural Philosophers.
Or, "People who loved truths concerning the world around them."
Natural philosophy in seventeenth-century
England was sort of like the contemporary
natural sciences mashed up with medicine,
mathematics, some philosophy–philosophy,
and a whiff of religion.
The word “scientist” was only coined recently,
in historical terms, in the 1830s, and caught
on around 1840.
It was made up by an English scientist named
William Whewell who was also a historian of
science and a priest.
So if we only cared about the history of people
called “scientists,” our job would be
easy: there aren’t any until around 1840!
And most people called scientists, or natural
philosophers, looked suspiciously similar
to one another.
Take the Royal Society: its members have been,
until recently, almost exclusively rich English
men.
Even though their ranks have included many
incredibly clever scientists, they haven’t
represented anything like all knowledge makers.
The sixty-second President of the Royal Society,
biophysicist Venkatraman Ramakrishnan, is
the group’s first non-white leader.
And there has never been a female President.
But the history of systematically knowing
stuff goes back much further than the Royal
Society and includes more types of people
than English blokes.
Thus “science” is a historical and social
concept—not one that’s existed forever,
in the same way for all people.
Because the history of science includes many
systems of understanding the world, we have
to consider these systems on their own terms.
It may seem simpler to focus on the “winners”
of history.
But hearing only the big Euroamerican names—Plato,
Einstein—doesn’t teach us as much about
our global system of science today.
Taking the time to highlight different knowledge
worlds will help us see our own as relatively
recent, not entirely unified, and evolving.
For example, we’ll learn about the Greco-Latin-Jewish-Arabic
medicine of the medieval Mediterranean world,
millennia of ayurvedic knowledge across the
Subcontinent, traditional Chinese medicine,
and Incan “talking knots” and engineering—just
to name a few.
Each of these systems has its own social norms
about what count as valid ways to make and
share knowledge.
We’ll look at modern scientific norms in
a later episode.
And each of these can help us see the “otherness”
of these past or different cultures as not
so other, after all.
We can see natural philosophers and other
proto-scientists as smart people making sense
of their world, not as “bad” scientists.
They understood the world around them in the
smartest way they could.
For example, according to medieval Mediterranean
medicine, the organ in my head was for venting
waste heat, not thinking.
People in the past weren’t stupid: they
knew that if your head was chopped off, that
was curtains for you.
They just weren’t sure what all this weird
gray stuff did.
Even today—though we can see a neuron fire
in high-resolution—we struggle to understand
what really goes on when it fires, that is,
the role a single neuron plays in thinking…
much less answer the question, what is consciousness.
The history of science really gets even juicier
when incremental, nagging questions about
the natural world add up and cause a scientific
discipline, or an entire society, to change
in a “revolutionary” way.
Later in the series, we’ll look at moments
of revolution within the sciences alongside
philosophers such as Thomas Kuhn and Michel
Foucault, who... did not always agree.
They show that science isn’t only historical
and social, but constructs entire worlds of
knowledge in which we all find ourselves trapped.
But don’t worry about that just yet.
By learning the history of science, we will
automatically start to think about our own
knowledge world as historical—not finished,
not capital-E enlightened.
Around the world, humans are still actively
working to understand our universe… but
they don’t all agree on how to do it.
We may be able to make more accurate models
of natural phenomena… but we may never find
the ultimate answers we seek.
At its limit, the history of science touches
on the study of religion: the diverse and
changing nature of the never-ending human
search for Truth, capital T.
Our path through past knowledge worlds is
going to be a beautiful and powerful one.
There are many, many marvelous insights to
celebrate.
To help us keep our footing as we jump across
centuries and continents, we’re going to
keep our eyes on five big questions.
Questions that, to this day, we do not have
complete answers to.
First: what is stuff?
From atoms to dark matter to spacetime: what
are things made of?
“Things,” by the way, includes air, fire,
and outer space:
if you think I’m going to sit here and not
celebrate the death of phlogiston with you,
you’re sorely mistaken!
Number two: what is Life?
What’s the simplest way to define living
things?
Are viruses alive?
Is the earth alive?
Where did life come from?
Where did current organisms come from?
How do we understand their interactions with
each other and their world?
Three: where are we?
What is this place, the earth?
What is its place in the cosmos?
Is this the only universe?
Four: when are we?
More questions of scale: how long have we
been around?
What about living things?
What about the whole universe?
What came before that?
And five: how can we agree on what we know?
And how can I convince more people that the
stuff I know is accurate?
For example, how can I show anti-vaccers that
vaccines are necessary!?
Regarding technology, how should we talk about
what to do what our knowledge?
All of these questions have been considered
by people as far back as records exist.
They also remain active areas of study today.
But the last theme is so important that it
gets its the final section.
Humans have always tried to describe the world,
for lots of reasons: in part because it’s
fascinating (“magnets—how do they work!?”),
and in part to control it.
Knowledge, as they told us in grade school,
really is power!
The power that knowing stuff gives the knower
is exactly why we should study the history
of science.
Thus one goal of this course is to highlight how the values (beliefs about  right and wrong) and ethics (acceptable behaviors)
of scientists and engineers shape our world.
And how, conversely, sciences and technologies are shaped by the societies that produce them.
We have a responsibility as citizens to understand
and to act accordingly.
Our world today looks radically dissimilar
to that of three hundred years ago.
To quote Andy Weir, we’ve “scienced”
the heck out of it.
We learned about stuff, made new technologies,
and are currently scrambling to learn new
stuff to solve the problems that our old technologies
created.
Facing an utterly unprecedented total ecological
catastrophe, we may need to “science”
it even more, in one way or another.
We’ll talk more about this in future episodes.
Learning the history of science can help shine
a light on this dark future.
Next time—pack your spanakopita: we’re
heading to ancient Greece to invent natural
philosophy with the Presocratics.
Until then, this has been—“on no one’s
word”—Crash Course: History of Science!
Crash Course History of Science is filmed
in the Dr. Cheryl C. Kinney Studio in Missoula,
MT and It’s made with the help of all of
these nice people.
And our animation team is Thought Cafe.
Crash Course is a Complexly production.
If you want to keep imagining the world complexly
with us, check out some of our other channels
like Sexplanations, How To Adult, and Healthcare
Triage.
If you'd like to keep Crash Course free for
everyone, forever, you can support the series
at Patreon, a crowdfunding platform that allows
you to support the content you love.
Thank you to all of our patrons for making
Crash Course possible with their continued support.